hey everyone
welcome we are
still on site in costa rica
at bentino massaro's shift into
permanent alignment
event having a blast talking to so many
of the
incredible retreat attendees
we are now bringing nadeem melhem onto
the show heineken
thanks for hello on thank you
yeah i'm happy to be here yeah i'm happy
to have met you nadeem
came from france exactly where in france
um in passing it's close to the mont
blanc
okay to mong blanc big white man
beautiful
we came all the way from france and
we've been vibing a lot especially on
relaxing back
into our awareness and relaxing back
into the playfulness and the perfection
that we are
exactly we've been vibing on it a lot to
like together and
we've had even some brilliant awakening
experiences together in doing so
whereas a lot of the time we have this
calling to go and socialize
to take the time to go inward can evolve
consciousness
awaken consciousness at an even more
profound level
just by taking a step back into silence
and relaxing into that awareness into
the i am the creator
abiding exactly yeah and it's
very important space to also come
together and abide
as one together so it's pretty easy
yeah exactly when you add another
two three four five plus a biting
powerful container formed yeah yes yeah
it's a powerful permission slip
to to stay present at the refresh rate
exactly the refresh rate is a good way
to put it
so it's almost like we'll talk about
this actually let's go ahead and outline
out
we called this episode enlightenment
because we're gonna
walk through sort of the most perennial
understanding of these fundamental steps
and so
ultimately it's already perfect it's
already perfection
and yet it's also perfecting
in the sense of recognizing its true
nature
so when you have somebody that is egoic
and they believe that they are a
separate finite
biological entity that they're not
aware of their awareness they're not
aware of that i am they're not aware of
that being impersonal and eternal
and they're not aware of themselves as
god or as source
or as infinity as the creator that is
then
creating these realities these dreamed
realities to experience
and so there these are sort of the
layers that we're going to go through
and that's what would mean as
enlightenment versus
as the finite contracted ego the ego is
trying to get
peace and happiness from the world it's
trying to extract it
by relationships substances experiences
whereas the enlightenment is bringing
peace and happiness
to the world yes by itself recognition
yes by itself recognition yeah so how do
you feel about that general system in
terms of going from
sort of the person consciousness
where even the subtlety of recognizing
consciousness
is not even there it's basically just
focused on
objects and trying to extract happiness
and peace from the world
and then basically the spiritual
awakening happens which is when the
consciousness becomes more expanded it
relaxes the contracted energy
into what is many times called a oneness
it begins feeling more of the cosmic
consciousness style and then it
begins to be more subtle because it
abides as awareness
right so it recognizes awareness being
fundamental and that this just being one
expression that awareness experiences
and then recognizing that oneself as the
creator even beyond
that and yeah so how do you feel about
that yes your question is like what is
uh a powerful entry point
um in my experience it's it's very
crucial to interrupt what you think you
are so to interrupt the stream of
thoughts
interrupts the identifications that we
don't know we have
or are associated with and uh
bentino masala shared a very powerful
tool
the two to five seconds is interrupting
but how it started in my experience was
not really with this pointer because i
didn't
know this articulation
it started kind of with the with reading
books and one of
his books was the power of now i love it
i could totally
exactly yeah and it's mainly about
stopping to think
or realizing that you can be aware of
the thinking
and seeing that it's not you and uh
so i have a twin brother and uh
i'm very grateful i'm a very privileged
that we could have this
uh reflection you know like
being able to investigate together
because often when being start to
be inspired or start to realize there is
something deeper
to this than what they think
how they what they know and it's kind of
like a
being alone like a lonely process of
like checking
and trying and not being sure and uh
it being a great contrast with the
surrounding the friends with the family
with the people that we have there
yeah the circle where we grow up in
and i had this privilege to to have that
with my brother
and uh at one point when you were
reading
in his books for for quite some time few
months i would say
we went to to visit our family in
germany
and when we were there we made this kind
of permissions with this tool that every
time
i would recognize them thinking
but just like the thoughts that you
think every day again
you know there's a high percentage of
the tasks that is just
coming from the previous days and we
would make this little
permission slip that every time i
recognize i i'm thinking so i can become
aware
that thinking is happening like in this
moment
you can become aware that there is a
stream of thoughts
appearing inside the space or inside of
your capacity to know it
capacity to observe it and every time
that
i would become aware of that i'll do
this
and it would trigger my brother
in
[Music]
i was thinking too because most of the
time we were just visiting our family
sitting in circles you know and they
were all talking arabic and
we obviously could not speak arabic so
there was not much engagement for us so
either we were sitting or we are driving
to the next
group of family because we're doing
sauron for a long long time and
they all want to see us so it was like
there was nothing for our mind to engage
with yeah yeah yeah
there was nothing to do for us than to
sit there and hear them speaking arabic
so we started to implement this and
every time
i would is that and then together okay
oh cool it's also kind of the
representation of here you remember then
there
and then together together yeah that's
great so and then
uh then it would be uh provoked or
invoked
to interrupt the string of dots to just
give away
for a few moments few seconds
and to abide in this space as long as
possible
until you again forget or
identify yourself with the tinker of the
dart
and then for example my brother would
recognize this and he would do this
and then i would be provoked and it
started to appear
to happen so rapidly like like synergy
yeah you know like really like a spiral
of warts
that after two three weeks we were able
to sit
and have a few dots in a few hours
perfect because you are really extreme
in it
because there was nothing else yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's great
wow and this opened the first real
like yeah window into like like my
identity
dissolving but not really knowing that
this was what was happening
but just knowing like there is
recognizing there is
so much freedom here like yeah yeah
wow this was very powerful
opening of the window to more of myself
yes i love that that's a great way to
kick it off so
how old were you um i was 15 16.
okay so 15 16 and you have a twin
brother
yes looks like you exactly that's cool
okay
cool that's really interesting seeing
i'm not visualizing you guys that young
doing
and that that's really a fascinating way
to sort of
create a trigger around the relaxation
from the cloud which
this would be a good time to go through
the analogy as well so we're talking
about stream entry which is sort of the
first
fundamental way to get yourself from a
more egoic level of physicalism to a
more subtle level of consciousness or
awareness
and in doing so
what you got to do is you have to begin
recognizing that the
thoughts and sensations and perceptions
that appear are like
transient clouds that arise and then
disappear
just like the waves on the ocean arise
and disappear
and so what is the space or the
container in which
they appear and disappear that is
awareness which is
this which is the sky where the clouds
appear and disappear
or which is the ocean where the waves
appear and disappear
and so you begin abiding as being said
done so when you feel the ability to
relax back you catch yourself entering
into that
timeless presence rather than being
contracted by
the thought of the object that then you
can make a signal for yourself
and friends to also abide and then over
time you get
so good at abiding that you can go for
hours on
end without having even a thought arise
yeah or several thoughts arise but over
a couple of hours which is very
fascinating
so and it doesn't like the thoughts can
come up
but it doesn't take you anymore yeah if
if you
for that moment like deliberately enough
what is the word yeah commit
to that then the pristineness
of the clear open sky like you said
becomes so vivid
that when a story appears you see it
directly
and you see it just emanate otherwise it
looks like it's you really believing
that yeah you're really thinking that
and that's very initial to start to see
this space
between you and the thinker perfect of
the dots
like the first distinction of
discrimination
exactly so there's a detachment that
happens
from the story over time and you become
less
sold into the thought stream
that would then take you on the monkey
mind adventure
and so you become less attached to it
you become more of a witness or an
observer to
it just happening and then arising and
then because you don't get attached to
it
it disappears rather than going on the
monkey mind
yes we got to a point where
throughout the retreat obviously over
the last
couple of years of practicing what we've
been talking about so far
we're able to in a sense instead of
going like this to trigger each other
we just basically look at each other and
then
just
we've been doing this the whole retreat
where
we would just start yeah looking at each
other and breathing and connecting to
that very
impersonal eternal awareness and the
creatorship
and then we would take a couple of those
breaths and just both abide as that and
then we would just giggle
because we know our nature yeah it's
like this giggle in the heart
from from the creator recognizing itself
and recognizing that it's recognized
seemingly
from two points exactly recognize that
we are looking from the same place
yes and this was with my twin brother
easier to see in the beginning
that we were looking from the same place
yeah somehow at one point
this was the recognition like
i guess yeah
the creator directly experiencing
its truth in its illusory
creation where the
agents seem to be so attracted to the
illusion to maya
so that when they take a moment to
recognize
their true permanent
source infinitude
and abide in that it's so funny
you too
yeah yeah it's so great because uh like
i
use the words of looking from the same
place but actually it's more like
looking from the same non-place because
otherwise he would be looking from
somewhere
inside there and i would be looking from
somewhere inside here
but because it's the creator recognizing
itself like you
um used the question uh that you could
provoke this recognition rate of like
do you know that we come from the same
source
because this is something you can
intuitively tune into
like it transcends the intellectual do
you know that
like do you heard that you can use it
that way too but you can also check like
do you
sense that there is only one source
that we are that one source yes that
everything
in its variety it's an expression of
that one source
expressing in infinite ways something so
beautiful for me it's like to see like
infinity that what is you
has to express itself in all the
infinite ways
exactly to be like the true
representation of infinity that's
exactly it yes
this is one song out of
an endless possibilities of
musical compositions or another way to
say it is that this is one way to
paint a blank canvas out of the
infinite possible ways to paint a blank
canvas this is one way
to put images together into a movie out
of the
infinite ways to put niches together
into movies
and so you'll never come to the end
that's where we've been that's where
we're going it's eternal
and that this is but one representation
one creation one playful
experience for us to yeah to undergo i i
like that
way of phrasing it as well i think it
more easily gives people
glimpses into their nature
even if they're at a more egoic or just
a stream entry level
because a lot of people can relate to
the
another way to say it is that how many
different ways can you vibrate your
vocal cords to make languages
yes how many different ways can you put
food
arranged food into recipes yeah and it's
very interesting because
it's a very important example
of seeing that the potential for every
possible
tone to come out is already there there
you go
the unique song is the way in which the
tones are organized
the way they come together the way that
they have silence in between
perfect and and the way they dance
together
how they interval and all these kind of
things
and that's then the unique expression
of consciousness the uniqueness that
that unique aspect of infinity that has
to be there or the whole
in the expressive sense is not complete
yes yes perfect so then this is like
in my experience the more that i
surrender
to the natural stream or the natural way
of being
the more that this out we can call it
authenticity
feels like it falls in its place that's
right like just a
physical experience of like clicks like
you you feel when when it's like a yes
yes yeah exactly so it's really cool
it's kind of like
like like playing music you play music
and you hear
when it says yes so you always have
a reference point does it sound good yes
does it mean everyone loves the same
music but you can feel even when it's
not your genre
that it sounds good yeah that's really
cool
yeah another way to potentially play on
that a little more is to say things like
that people that are abiding in more
enlightened states
they play more in tune they vibe more
in tune and then those that are in a
more egoic state
they create dissonance
disharmony that there's a
in the symphony there's playing out of
tune
yes and so based on the level
of purification that once went under
so we gave the example of the thought
stream and then entering into the
thought stream
by recognizing that
the clouds of thoughts sensations and
perceptions
appear inside of
the sky of awareness so
relax
back into the sky of awareness
especially with your eyes closed taking
inhalations
and then become more subtle around
recognizing
when the thought cloud arises
and then detach yourself from it so that
it doesn't take your monkey mind for a
wander
but that it just disappears and then you
recognize even more subtly
the fact that you're the awareness in
which the cloud arose and disappeared
so that's stream entry that's the way to
conquer that level
and go ahead you go and then yeah and
you can really
relax your your brain and your eyes
like that like we often we look like
this and then
the moment we relax the eyeballs like
physically and
the brain kind of as if it goes to sit
instead
it's standing like it starts to sink let
it relax
perfect
and then when when you notice that
a thought form or any kind of sensation
arises don't feel like it should not be
there
just notice it without
engaging with it without jumping on that
train of thought
and like as non judgmental or
caring in a sense as you
can in this moment
but every time you notice it you just
gently bring your awareness or your
attention
back to being because it's not really
you that jumps on the train of thought
it's more
your attention that is now engaged
married with the thought perfect
so then you know it is okay this one of
my most
profound powers is the attention yes so
i shifted to being
to the sense that or the knowing that
there this is kind of the only thing you
are
100 sure of in this moment is that
somehow you have to be
first yes in order to recognize
that's right the thought or the
sensation
so you can use whatever appears
as an indication that you are
yeah and this is very powerful because
then it doesn't matter what appears
you can feel like you're all wounded up
and your mind is going crazy still
if you ask yourself what does it
indicate directly
okay that somehow that has to be the
capacity
here to know that this is appearing
automatically there is more space
like zooming out
yeah what's most fundamental is the
being
is the awareness is the in a sense
the formless container in which
all of the thoughts and emotions
sensations perceptions beliefs
objects appear and disappear
make that subtle distinction and abide
more as that formless sky
of beingness and awareness that then is
the container
for the clouds
yeah that's so perfect yeah keep going
and it does become
easier to be able to see
that there is a space between you and
what appears
so it's just a matter of like one of the
previous like it's the only video i saw
to this moment from atlas to the one
about earnestness
is very powerful entry point to that
because it's really about
where you perceive the most benefit are
you really desiring
deeper freedom because if you do
automatically
you care more about abiding in being
than in engaging or being married with
the appearances and being lost in it
sleeping in it perfect so kind of all
the
all the catalytic experiences that we
have all going to retreats and
it's kind of like a big portion of being
here
is about the inspiration first of the
being
and how they are what they are
constituted as and what they radiate and
and represent inspires you to desire
that
more than the confused way that you are
living perfect
and this in itself allows you
to have the natural shift in choice
to abide instead then to sleep in the
dark
you know yeah humility
is key to say i know i know not
or i know i do not know and so if you
can
humbly say that
i am suffering i am
unsure i'm confused about
these thoughts that take me on these
wild rides
and then i end up
hurting myself or hurting my family or
my friends by getting
angry or yelling or have catalyzing some
sort of disharmony
the first step is to recognize that that
is the case
and then to humbly say i know i know not
and then to tune in to what we're
talking about here
which is the perennial wisdom of how
to take that first step into the stream
entry and earnestness
is key as nadine said
that do you want
to enter into your thought stream and
become
more liberated more illuminated
more enlightened more radiating
love like the sun unconditionally
or do you want to stay steeped in the
confusion
and so use your choice
to be earnest
yes i think this is a powerful
entry point in um maybe giving some
uh or sharing some pointers or
kind of like an understanding and
mapping of how beliefs work
because it's um please yeah
it's like uh a lot of in what we share
in this retreat or what vintiniya shared
also
is based on the work of the loved one
a book of the law of one contact
and they're they share that it's kind of
like
three steps of faces and the first one
is to know yourself
with to know your stuff to know your
conditioning to know your patterns your
behavior
to be aware of them to be able to
acknowledge them
and the second step is to accept them to
see that they are
the already acceptedness and the third
step is to become
the creator
to really experientially be the creator
not just in essence but the words that
atlas used to perfect
the perfected is to become the creator
and this first step of knowing yourself
in a way it's
uh kind of tricky like um
because the whole thing is that the ego
effect
does everything in its power to stay
alive
so it has a lot of sneaky ways to
keep asking
me it's kind of like it's associating
for your attention this is like
the root of it and
to be able to to acknowledge
when a belief comes up let's say you're
triggered like a negative belief comes
up and you're triggered
it's not pleasant right so there is
something that automatically wants to
avoid that or run away from that or
blame or whatever
what we normally do and
a very simple entry point in that is
like recognizing
how much it hurts like how much it hurts
when you are
trying to avoid or not see the
belief is there and in the moment that
you acknowledge it
there is so much more space like you
don't have to do anything with it
just like the acknowledging okay this
thing is disappearing
it is there it is not defining me but it
is appearing
and one of the yeah one of the very
powerful things that they shared in this
retreat
was about uh it's kind of like seeing
that
all this conditioning is not yours
it's not your fault you are meant to be
conditioned
you are meant to identify yourself
with the understanding of this
collective and you grow up you learn the
ways of
the civilization in subtle telepathic
ways
in verbal ways uh in many ways in
all kinds of social settings
so you are meant to behave like that
it's your choice in a sense from a
deeper space
but to to keep it to this point you
don't have a choice
up to you recognize that you have the
choice up to you can have
some space some manner of space between
you
and the conditioning or the conditioned
self
and this is powerful this was powerful
in my experience because then you can
let go of your sense of self-worth more
and more to be attached
to acknowledging that you are full of
[ __ ]
acknowledging that there is a
conditioned sleepy way
active within your being or that
potential is
still there for you to choose out of
your free will
to merge your action with that to
believe that
it's your power like um
like uh kind of a synopsis of what are
three more uh fundamental powers
is the power of intention the power
of belief to believe something to agree
upon something
and the power to identify to
merge your sense of i your sense of
innermost sense being
with what appears in and as being
you could say with what appears inside
of the view
if you were to comment something i
continued
like there's so much joy for for us to
share about this because we know how
it really frees you up that's right yes
and
you no longer become a slave in a cage
to the monkey mind taking you every
single
day for countless rides yes
and rather you become
liberated and free on a moment-to-moment
basis
absorbed in your true nature which then
enables sachin and that existence
consciousness bliss
and you from your heart radiate that
like the sun
and it just becomes your true everyday
experience which then butterfly effects
onto your
family friends people online
the community the world etc yeah
it's that's why we even share it correct
because it's that
liberating and freeing and important for
also igniting the
global awakening yeah
something or some way that is very
powerful
for you in this moment to tune into
is to to look really look in this moment
like
how much it is actually hurting you
how much you actually feel uh
mixed confused like you're all over the
place and
you you yeah
just from a simple place like how much
it's actually
hurting you
just to stay there for a little moment
and
to ask yourself what do you truly want
like what is the the intention of the
reason why you are even
listening to us because if you are here
and you state listening
there is a deeper desire for being here
perfect and
if that
if it is clear for you in this moment or
to whatever degree
you you feel clear about it and it is to
to be more free or to
to recognize the freedom that you
already are
perfect then one of the really powerful
questions that we got this week was what
will it
take for you how big does the catalyst
has to be before you would apply
let's say just to make it a little bit
more accessible
70 of your attention to
your freedom
like really look for yourself in this
moment
what is the moment what should
happen before you allow yourself before
you direct 70
of your attention to being committed to
your self only your true self freedom
this can be relaxing the thoughts being
more honest
whatever it is that you have access to
what will it take
will you respond to the feather
that is doing a little hey
catalyst
pay more attention to that which sees
rather than that which is seen
and if you do that
you if you commit yourself with more
than
70 percent intent to be like
i'm gonna become that which sees instead
of that which is seen
then you will not need
the sledgehammer
which
and this moment is the feather the
imagination
is the feather it's if you really
imagine this for a moment
then it means that there is enough
desire within you
or that you choose for that to be the
case to use and
use this catalyst catalytic moment to
the best of your abil
to the best of your ability before it
has to become the sledgehammer
and the reason why we ask you this
question or why i ask you this question
is because if you can check and you see
okay
if this would happen for example all my
current friends
would hate me disguise me my family
would not want to communicate with me
anymore
i would lose my apartment and i would
just
have to become fully present to tap into
my full power
wandering around this world and really
taking it all the way like fully playing
choosing to go out in
this is a little bit more than 70 but
just to use the example
then check for yourself you can also
choose 100 percent
like take whatever feels the most
powerful for you
and then ask yourself if that would be
the consequence
so either that happens or you choose to
be
true to yourself seventy percent or one
hundred percent
from this moment on and and let's even
take
it another step
fundamentally to even the question
what do you desire
[Music]
because when you desire
that's what you're putting at your north
star
location yes and so
if you first of all are not aware
of what you desire that means that
you're so jumbled up and confused
that you don't even have something in
your north star location
so be become aware of that first
and then second is that okay i am aware
that i'm jumbled up that i don't
necessarily have something in that north
star location so now it's
take time take time
take 30 minutes take an hour take a
whole day
even to just go out into nature and
reflect
what do i want to put in that north star
location
because the moment when you put
liberation or freedom or enlightenment
or my true nature i want to know myself
that's why the delphic maxim
know thyself was written on the top of
the temple of apollo at delphi
2 500 years ago because it was the north
star
and that way when you put something
there every day
what you'll do is you'll wake up
and you'll remember that there's
something in that north star position
and your days will become more and more
less confusing and more and more geared
toward
desire which is that freedom or that
liberation or that true nature
that metaphysical insight of knowing
yourself
of knowing our true nature so
that's a critical component to it and
then
put earnestness towards that
so if you put one percent earnestness
towards it you're gonna be a snail
in france they know about snails
yeah i'm not really from france yeah i'm
living in france
i'm from belgium and they also speak
about escargot it's called
and if you do two percent you'll tiny
faster snail not much faster
you know you really have to work your
way up to putting in 25
50 75 earnestness towards that
north star desire for you to actually be
able
to liberate yourself become free
recognize your true nature
these types of things because if and
here's what it would look like
if you actually began putting let's say
50 percent of this towards the desire of
freedom
50 is a lot but this is what it would
look like
that would mean that at least half
of your day so you're going to spend
about 16
hours awake that means you're going to
spend
eight hours of the day
on freedom that means you might
read the power of now by eckhart tolle
that means you might just relax
for an hour and try and become more
aware
of awareness itself and as you do those
repetitions
you'll become less attached to those
thought clouds
and so that means for those eight hours
if you're 50
earnest that means you'll spend eight
hours
per day on that north star desire
of freedom and guess what compound
interest
is the eighth wonder of the world the
more earnestness that you put at a
younger
age when you have greater
neuroplasticity
the more you'll get compound interest in
your
30s 40s 50s
you'll become a gnostic being you'll
know the true nature
you'll radiate out love
and peace like the sun
and you'll butterfly affect that out to
everything you do and touch
at a younger age because you'll have put
more earnestness into it
it's really great and uh
like let's say that your north star
is truly um to recognize yourself
as the freedom that you are
but yeah with the thought stream
is telling you in this moment that you
cannot you know that you are not capable
to for 50 percent so eight hours a day
dedicate yourself to ourselves because
you're too jumbled up or whatever
then this imagination that we shared
and also another one afterwards is very
powerful because
if you imagine either a consequence or
something amazing
you will see that you can do it so if
the consequence is
high high enough so you always have to
imagine until it really clicks until you
feel it like wow yeah
if this was the consequence then i could
do it
and if you find this place in yourself
where you see like i could do it if this
was the consequence
it means you can do it because if you
could do it then it means you can do it
now
just you don't want it bad enough badly
another way of putting it that i heard
that was very powerful for me was like
if someone would give you five million
a month for example if you would stay
eight or if you would dedicate
or prioritize eight hours a day to your
freedom
could you do it of course you could
i could do it you can do it everyone in
this retreat
can do it doesn't mean everyone is doing
it
so this is just like ways of playing uh
checkmating
the uh the condition itself using its
own way of looking
to counter itself perfect i'm going to
have a little pee perfect and all that's
great timing because i'll go ahead and
i'll explain what was coming up for me
so as the dean was just saying that
bentino also has a pretty aggressive way
of putting it as well
which is that if you are
to have a forcible experience where
somebody
takes a gun points it towards your head
and says
stop all descriptions
for two to five seconds stop describing
your experience for two to five seconds
what happens you take a breath
quiet down and you melt into
the fact that you're aware
and that's it that's why
2 000 plus years ago you had
the yoga sutras of patanjali and that's
why
2500 years ago you had the buddha
and the four noble truths
what they say is they say yogas
union is simply
the cessation of the fluctuations
of mind it's that simple
so if you get these forcible experiences
that make it so that you have to stop
for two to five seconds repeatedly
force yourself
and watch as what happens
is that you get to relax
stop describing your experience
relax into the very fact of
i am
that beingness
that awareness
and reside there for as long as you can
now if you reside there for two to five
seconds
that's fantastic
that's great that's beautiful
that's a whole level up from being
confused
without a north star it's a huge level
up
and that's gonna very clearly as richard
has been sharing with us at the retreat
as well who's teaching alongside bentino
for about a day and a half is that then
everything that you learned will become
very
clearly evident in your
behavior as
all of the great mystic traditions say
and as they teach
is the pause the
pause when you
do this practice for two to five seconds
what's going to happen is the pause
itself
is going to increase
you're going to abide longer and longer
in the
i am in the beingness
in the awareness
and as that pause lengthens from 2
seconds to 5 seconds to 10 seconds to 15
seconds
what's gonna happen is you will
experience more and more
subtle levels of enlightenment
and then it's to understand that
you are
the nature of reality you are exactly
what you
seek you are the creator of
awareness and of these worlds
and you create them eternally endlessly
to play in a process
called lila the divine play of
hiding and seeking of forgetting
and remembering endlessly through
all of these different design potentials
and then so you'll abide as that and
that'll be even more enlightened
because you'll recognize yourself as the
creator
you'll recognize the creator in every
single person you'll recognize the
creator
in every single experience
serving your awakening serving
everyone's awakening
you'll recognize the creator in our
beautiful
planet in our beautiful environment
in the birds chirping in the drinks of
water that you have in the bites of food
that you eat
and that's all that's meant by
enlightenment you
radiate out the sunlight of knowing your
true nature
now i go perfect now you take over
i love you so much
yeah and every moment
has this potential
to recognize that you are
because it's the case in every moment
and it's really easy to see it's like
it's not something difficult or
far away or
it's the very fact that you have to be
in order to hear this voice to hear the
sounds
the very fact that you have to be in
order to
watch this video so it's already the
case
and the only thing that it requires
from your answer to speak is to
recognize it
to recognize the fundamental isness
of beingness
the substratum
of this moment of this
togetherness the one expressing itself
seemingly different
sides of the screen like we are on this
side of the screen and seemingly are
there on that side of the screen
but still it's the same same one
awareness
like atlas uses the worst shared
awareness
a lot in our communication it's very
powerful because
just to tune into that for a moment like
it's a
shared awareness because we come from
the same
source the awareness
is shared yes exactly
so there is intrude that is
verifiable in this moment there is no
distance between you
being on that side of the screen and we
be on this side of the screen
because that assumption
that engagement with thoughts
saying i am here inside of this body
the engagement with the sensation of i
am this feeling this sensation this
being this body
is observable you are
formless and you are non-local
that's what your consciousness your
awareness is
that's what our true nature is
we are that formlessness
experiencing first
before we are of the descriptors
descriptions of i am this
body in costa rica
and you are that body in your
location in the world because this needs
dots it needs thinking right so even
this is why it's so powerful
even to relax all dots for two to five
seconds
and we can do it again now
in this few seconds was there
or is that separation
can you find anywhere separation without
having to think about it first
[Music]
without having to create the thought ah
this is
separate this is there this is here and
this is
the distinction of the space between it
so if it takes thinking if it takes
something that has to
in order for you to say i am over here
separate from you on that side of the
screen then it's not real that it's not
fundamental then it's not what you are
if it appears and disappears
it's not what you are because you are
still there when it disappears
so how could it be you perfect
how could it ever be who we truly are
we've never actually experienced a
birth or a death
we just tell some stupid story for
children and then it creates a little
egoic hitchhiker
then we have to work our whole lives
on kicking the ego cut hitchhiker out of
the
car otherwise you get to the end of your
life
and you're there
and you're laying there in the death bed
and thought about being fine at your
whole life you were finite your
whole life
and so everything you did was about
being finite
and never once did infinity
come never once infinity
or abiding as even awareness
come so a question
desire do you want
to know your true nature do you want to
liberate yourself from suffering
do you want to become a more advanced
jedi
and if that is what you want
then acknowledging the negative beliefs
and the nonsense within
yourself is crucial
because there is other way
because you are meant to
to engage to identify with
this conditioning like continuous shared
in this retreat
the way he articulates it
is that your whole body and mind
is made out of the stuff of this planet
it is made out of the ways of this
planet the conditioned
behavior of the splash planet the ways
of thinking
the dna of the mixes of all the beings
and
your your individual
body mind spirit complex or the body
mind in this moment
is that so to
to to just recognize that for a moment
gives you some some context
to to being okay with
acknowledging that this is happening
within you it is not you
but it is happening within you and every
moment that this negative belief
whatever name you believe is triggered
first it will do a little bit of this
you know it because
it's based on this hitchhiker
thank you guys because maybe to give a
little bit more background
for me the word enlightenment partially
means to lighten
the load and the other aspect is
to be fulfilled with light yes
but when you lighten the load it's
automatically instantaneously fulfilled
with
light illumination illuminated so
when you this is why it's in the first
phase or the first step the first thing
to bring your attention to
is to know yourself to become aware of
your patterns your behavior your way of
thinking who you think you are all of
this
yeah and then acknowledge it that is
acknowledgement
and the second step is the acceptance
of what you are perceiving but in a way
what you are describing was already the
second step because the moment you
really acknowledge is there
it is seen in the already acceptedness
because you only stop running you're
only running away from what you see
until you you see you are free from it
you can see that it's already accepted
it's okay there was a few moments in our
communication
this week that i shared with him some
negative
belief that i saw and for the first
reason why i can't share this negative
belief is because i know at some
degree that i am already free from that
because i
started with other negative beliefs so
then it builds
the power the conviction that even this
one i am not but
somehow i still believe in a way that i
am that
so then by sharing that exposing that
you already diminish
the believability in it and to then have
a reflection from a being
that is you but that seems to be
having an authority in that moment
against your
uh now lousy mind or nonsensical mind
is very powerful because it can be
instant like he reflects he speaks what
you already know
perfectly and this is the same what is
happening here this is why you maybe
feel like wow this this resonates like
this is resonance
what is resonance is about like i
already know i am this
and i'm now just create out of my power
these two amazing beings
reminding me of what i am perfect
yes perfect yes
and then it's also easier you know like
the more you can tune
into listening to this moment like it is
me speaking to me
directly to whatever degree you have
intuitive access to that
even if it's not your full experience
all the time you can tune into that
because it's the reality it's more
real to tune into than believing
creating the
thought that we are separate because for
that second option you have to do
something
create something make it appear
but for the most fundamental it is not
this is why it is real it is always real
yes
and remember that you can't
pull the flower to make it grow faster
so naturally the blossoming is happening
naturally yet you do
have the will
as you experience disharmony as you
experience
suffering
you do have the choice
all the time as you experience
those negative emotions it's an
emotional guidance system
telling you do you want to pursue this
top desire
freedom because if you do take this
most uplifting path most people are
closed off
to this path they're only open to these
paths
and most people if they don't listen to
the emotional guidance system they go in
this direction
you shared a little already on your
channel about the emotional organic
system
yeah we following your excitement we
have great yeah
yeah just that there is some contrast
yeah
yeah great yeah
maybe there is a specific video that
they can go to
if they didn't saw it yet just very very
briefly emotions
work to teach you about your true nature
they're trying to get you to align to
your true nature
most simply put emotions arise as a
teacher
for you to align with your true nature
more for you to know yourself more
for you to not suffer in the future for
you to make the decisions
to not suffer in the future
treat it like a lesson that's coming to
you
that's teaching you suffering is the
drill sergeant
of the awakening yeah so it's a positive
thing
like this is something that you can
actually practice
to start to perceive that when you feel
triggered in a positive way
this is very powerful for me uh to
really see like okay
every time that i do feel contraction
and i do feel an unpleasant emotion
there is an indicating that i
have a belief that is out of alignment
with the actual truth
the structure of the creation of what i
am of what is
fundamentally true it's the only true
guidance you have
direct guidance then i see okay this
means that i
am 100 connected
because i am connected to my own
guidance to
my guidance system it means that i am
100
unconditionally loved because it keeps
on knocking on the back door of my
heart until i open every time when i
perceive
something should be different and it's
lacking here and
there is anger or frustration if i keep
telling myself that story the anger will
become
more angry will amplify
so it is so unconditional you are
so loving yourself that you will keep
knocking
until you open
and in the same way you are guiding
yourself
through excitement yes where to bring
your focus
instead of like you're perceiving
something wrong like here this is the
next breadcrumb in the trail for you to
now act upon or
bring your attention on your
your whole beings or your focus
towards and
like this shift indication of starting
to follow what feels good what was truly
good
resonance the joy the excitement came
from
the formula of bashar i don't know if
you are familiar with this
it's uh that's your consciousness
channel through anger
and the formula very quickly is to act
upon your highest excitement
to the best of your abilities whatever
is in the range of
what is what you are able to act upon in
that moment you choose the best option
like the hand exactly so choose the
highest
not the other ones highest
and you do that and take that as far as
you can
until you can not take it any far so for
example
you have a direction something that
excites you
you act upon that until you cannot take
it any further and then from that point
you have to take a new avenue again what
is the highest excitement
instead of interpretating uh something
went wrong here there is a wall here and
block no you just
see it's not about the result we are not
going somewhere
it's just a navigation tool okay now
what is the highest band
and then very powerful part of it
but the mind somehow always seems to
forget it and it is with zero
insistence what's the outcome yeah
in the desire space you're seeking
you're seeking
peace and happiness from the attainment
of an object or an experience
or a relationship and
when you say i will be happy once
i have that house is misery
so you do karma yoga where
you pursue that excitement in the north
star position
that is not about getting
a carrot from maya but instead it is
about
a transcendent noble aim that is
in service to other people it's
to the ignition of the global awakening
it's in service because that's
ultimately what's going to bring you
most happiness it's ultimately what's
going to bring you most
peace is to know your true nature and
then to become
in service to other people and so having
that up there
and then pursuing that with the greatest
amount of excitement
and then completely liberating yourself
of any of the fruits from
the attainment of set goals and you will
bump into that
many times that you think like oh i'm
just acting upon it because it excites
me i don't care about the other i'm
so selfish i'm so selfless i already
know i'm a hundred percent selfless
yeah bentino made it really clear he's
like he's been
doing the self-purification engine for
the last couple of years
and we have these ten thousand layers of
deception
yeah self-deceit yeah self-deceit and so
you know even for what
i was reflecting on myself yesterday i
finally got to one of those layers
and that i'm gonna keep getting excited
about recognizing
more of these layers or impurities in
this service to other
true purity that we must have to make
sure there's no
holes on the ship of the igniting the
global awakening
which was that
this level of excitement
from other people
me for the truth
so oh as in as in we can get
excited or even a little bit egotistical
from the fact that people are asking us
about the true nature of what's
happening
of who we are and so it's important to
completely liberate yourself
from that to purify that impurity
so that you no longer gain pleasure
from people inquiring
to you because you know because there is
no person here that knows
this is only intelligent infinity
interacting with itself
there's no atlas unit here that knows
it's just the truth coming through
that's all it is and so that's a good
way to liberate yourself from the
impurity
is to recognize that this is a shared
dream
that you don't exist
that it's just the truth playing with
itself
awakening itself after falling asleep
in the dream and that's eternally being
explored
but those are some higher level
non-duality understandings
but you even in a lower understanding
talking to myself from a couple of years
ago
recognize that when you go to sleep at
night and you
dream that you
dream you simulate the environment
and you simulate the observer in the
environment you simulate
both and after you wake up from your
dream
maybe you were hanging out at the
base of the eiffel tower in your dream
ask yourself
did that experience happen
the one that i dreamed where i was at
the base of the eiffel tower
hanging out very simply
and the answer that question is no
it did and it didn't
ultimately no
but simultaneity yes
this is happening and it's not
it is a symphonic expression
and it's also a dream
and so that's a way also to liberate
yourself it's partly some of that neo
advice
appointing is to liberate yourself even
from your person consciousness
liberate yourself even from
the unit the form the identity that you
carry
let's let's let's route this is very
very powerful also the dynamic that
happens
it's kind of the same as how most of the
retreat was based
that we would go to a more abstract
metaphysical
zooming out and then to a more practical
point or more tangible way of
tool or technique or permission slip and
then merging the two like the relative
and the metaphysical
yes um yes so yeah
really just to to play with that within
ourselves
okay we have some tools we have
permission slips and i'm also speaking
to myself
because i have a lot of joy
and excitement for seeing how permission
slips work like how
the mechanism the structure the fabric
of things work
first for myself to see these things to
to be able to shift them easier or
faster how the mechanism of shifting
itself
works the mechanism of choice for
example that
every time that i perceive more benefit
in option a and option b
i will automatically choose option a
it's just
automatic until i perceive more benefit
i benefit my perceived benefit shifts my
choice shifts right but all of this
understanding is still a permission slip
and every permission slip is only to
come
to the recognition that you have free
will free choice and with this free will
you can inquire upon your own nature
more directly
more instantly and this is the
the more subtle levels of oh you can say
more self-realization oriented than
self-actualization
but eventually the two parts they are
just assisting each other are one
emerging coming together it's kind of
like you build up this capacity to rest
as being more
to also having a more
understanding of the fabric of things
and
to apply yourself right also to be
actively of service and
to purify your service exactly so you
can become more genuine
hmm
two to five seconds relax
relax do it do the repetitions
put noble aims in the north star
position
recognize yourself as the creator
that which endlessly explores
these realities and let yourself be
guided
by that's what sparks you your joy your
excitement
your calling your calling yeah [ __ ] yeah
we adore you thank you so much for
tuning in we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
leave us a comment let us know how you
feel
if you if the video brought you value
give it a like helps that youtube
algorithm
subscribe if you haven't to the channel
also we'll put some of nadeem's links
in the bio below you can go and check
out
that as well and
share the video with people that you
feel like it would make a profound
influence on
and take these very simple actionable
steps
to help us catalyze
igniting the global awakening thank you
thank you everyone
great boom much love